justin trudeau est né en 1971 à ottawa
au moment où son père pierre elliott
trudeau était premier ministre du canada
il passe donc une grande partie de son
enfance au 24 sussex
puis il vivra quelques années à montréal
avant de déménager en colombie
britannique pourrait étudier et
enseigner en 2000 justin trudeau se
faire remarquer lorsqu'il prononce
l'éloge funèbre de son père devant les
caméras de télévision
sept ans plus tard il fait le saut en
politique et remporte l'investiture
libérale dans papineau à montréal
élu député l'année suivante il succède à
michael ignatieff comme chef du parti
libéral du canada en 2013
négliger en début de campagne électorale
il est finalement porté à la tête d'un
gouvernement majoritaire en octobre 2015
31 ans après la fin du règne de son père
[Musique]